and let me ask you this question
when Republicans have been in charge of
the house
the Senate the White House or the
governor's mansion or State Rep and
state senators or the legislature
because 31 States right now they control
both Chambers a significant number of
them in the South where the majority of
black people are please show me
show me empirical data how the lives of
black people have fundamentally changed
on the Republican rule I'll wait do do
you know who started getting more votes
from the black community do you know who
your favorite guy
Republicans control all three branches
in South Carolina yeah they control
Georgia they control Mississippi they
control Arkansas they control Tennessee
so they can they control the legislature
in North Carolina so let me so since you
you I'm gonna use your argument please
show me please please show me how
at the live African Americans are
drastically improved in those places
where Republicans completely control
than other places
show me
give me an example
Roland if you would have answered any of
my questions oh my God if you would
answer any of my questions
you don't like the answer no it's not I
don't like the answer you like the
answer you you say tell me the policies
I'm asking you the policies oh so so I
can't I can't ask you a question you can
but I would like I brought you here
invite me on your show and I'll give you
the answer no I'm the guest wait wait
wait I brought you on the show first of
all you know my show if somebody asked
me a question hell I answer the question
I've answered your questions you still
can't answer it and the reason why you
can't answer it's been an hour you still
haven't answered the question I have you
have not actually I have what policy
here's why you haven't answered you
blame the state no no you blame
surrounding cities no you blame
Republicans that's what you blame no no
foreign
for 59 years and first of all systemic
racism is a policy because it's actually
ingrained in our system that's first
what I'm also saying to you is what I
recognize is how do we fix these again
institutions how do we fix them first
first and foremost first and foremost we
gotta stop denying that actually it's a
problem which you have done oh no first
I just showed you it's a problem 27 out
of 30. it is a problem you've got to
stop it's a big problem stop denying the
59 years Democrats have had to vote and
denied the systemic reality of racism in
the housing appraisal industry by going
I need to see the 47 million you just
denied it and one million percent I need
to see the data and I want one million
percent I need to keep I need to see
today here's the deal and by the way
credibility to New York Times here's the
deal oh okay fine yeah do you want to
pull up what first of all you gave it a
Heritage report
you read a New York Times report citing
a Heritage Foundation dude really wait
you're telling me New York Times got a
lot of credibility that's what you're
saying you live now I just told you you
referenced the Heritage Foundation dude
come on that's the daily signal that's
the daily signal who owns them I don't
even know who owns daily six here it is
foundation okay great I've done their
show so that's an in-house organization
here's what I'm telling by the way go to
it go to another side deal to give 27
out of 30. I'm going back I'm going back
but you still won't even answer and this
is what I'm telling you
you can't even show me now I'm gonna use
Mississippi since Mississippi has the
highest concentration of black people of
any state in America
but Republicans have ruled that state
since the Mississippi constitutional
convention in 1891 not a single
African-American has been elected
Statewide in Mississippi so if
Republicans control the governor's
mansion the hot the the legislature in
Mississippi
how then since you talk about the
policies how is it the lives of
African-Americans have not improved in
Mississippi if you say it's it's the
Democrats is their policies show me tell
me how it hasn't improved in Mississippi
uh Roland until you give me your answers
on the questions I've asked I gave you
the answer you're gonna go to the one
specific example no and this is what I
will tell you sippy here's what I will
tell you Arkansas Tennessee South
Carolina North Carolina Georgia I've
given you multiple States you still
haven't answered the question I've
answered your question no you have not
you don't like the ends no you have not
answered the question you blamed and
deflected you don't like the answers
what is the answer you don't like the
answer what's the answer your answer is
tell me about Memphis it's deflect
that's what reflection it's the first
one I never even brought up Memphis not
Memphis Mississippi Mississippi no I'm
giving you an example of what no because
it's you you have an extra money
let me say it again
I'm telling you what have you done about
it you say it since you said yeah since
you said oh my God you Democratic votes
show me in Republican red as reading
States how they have improved the lives
of African Americans
show me Roland Roland I don't think you
understand what I'm saying to you right
now I understand let me let me ask a
question for you what is your method of
helping black African Americans go ahead
tell us first and foremost when we talk
about helping African Americans I'm
going to acknowledge what a systemic and
what is systemic
systemic yeah defined systemic is when
you have the housing appraisal that's
systemic okay okay systemic is when you
have a higher proportion four to five
times of black children who are being
expelled or arrested in school compared
to White's kids that's systemic now no
no no no no you asked how first and
foremost we have what's Community we
have what's systemic what's Community
Based which means the village or also
what is individual when you start
talking about how do you make
transformations in this country first
and foremost you have to deal with the
two most important things health and you
deal with the issue of Education when
Republicans and conservatives were
talking about get rid of Roe v Wade I
literally say it okay gotcha and I had I
had been Watson the former NFL player
come on he did a documentary on the
issue of abortion and I said Ben here's
the fundamental problem when I hear
pro-life I said they're not pro-life
the anti-abortion I said because the
people who are so-called pro-life I said
show me the policies when they confront
the infant mortality rate among
African-Americans show me when they
confront the higher number of black
women who are dying in childbirth these
people who are having children he said
you can't they literally can't and so
that's a that's an example when you talk
about again Health we're talking about
uh uh a prenatal care we talk about
those issues that means that if you're a
black child and you have a higher
incident of black women who are dying in
childbirth Serena Williams see it ain't
just money thing Serena Williams talked
about all her money how she almost died
in childbirth because white doctors were
not listening to her do you know the
opioid crisis why it initially was
killing more white people
you know why tell us because doctors in
America
the study showed it doctors were saying
we're not going to prescribe the opioids
to African-Americans because we think
they're coming to us for drugs so y'all
gotta take Tylenol so they were over
prescribing Oxycontin and all these
powerful medical meds well and I said
well my goodness thank God the one-time
racism benefited black people we were
not over prescribe uh uh uh Oxycontin
and other bills of appeals the white
death rate has the the average average
length of whites Living in America has
dropped largely because of the opioid
crisis what I'm so that's systemic that
is systemic in your system how do we fix
the sex so but first of all the way you
first of all fix anything systemic you
even acknowledge that it's systemic
that's first two then you have to have
your data and then then go in and say
okay now let's now confront the reality
what we're facing you cannot have in
schools where you have largely white
teachers who don't know how to handle
black kids whose automatic call is call
the cops
where you now have kids who are in
kindergarten first grade who now are
being handcuffed and now taken down to
jail what you have to deal with is in a
school system how do you deal with those
children but also where they're coming
from what's one of the issues I thought
the numerous superintendents and
teachers one of the biggest things that
kids are coming to school hungry
when Republicans when you talk about who
you talk about food it's about porn
when they wanted to cut SNAP benefits I
was sitting here going
now explain that to me how we got the
richest prosperous country in the world
and we want to cut food benefits to folk
who are hungry
kids teachers principals superintendents
have said one of the biggest things that
we're facing are kids who literally are
coming to school who are hungry that's
why they can't study probably got
discipline problems so now okay
this down how do we deal with that we
have to acknowledge that even exists
what we can't do is from a macro
political levels go oh oh these folks
y'all just don't want to work it's
called The Working Poor for a reason
they are working
I'm not gonna just throw people under
the bus and go oh you're just you're
just ignorant you don't want to work I'm
acknowledging what the fact of the
matter is when the Republican governor
of Alabama about 10 years ago he wanted
to change the tax code
and he used Jesus as the model
he said
folks in Alabama they were taxing the PO
they were taxing people beginning at
forty six hundred dollars I think it was
forty six hundred dollars was 9 600. he
said these are poor people
he used evangelicals why conservative
evangelicals he used he's campaigning
Jesus talked about how we helped the
poor blah blah blah blah he wasn't his
whole deal
when it came time to vote what you think
happened
lost
65-35 so the same folk who love Jesus
the Same folk who holla oh I'm pro-life
and I love me some Jesus and I'm an
Evangelical no when it came to that no
they voted with a pocketbook because
they were saying ah those broke poor
people a republican governor a
conservative Evangelical they said no no
it's not pocketbook
problem we have in this country is we
are frauds when we talk about we care
about the poor
we are fraudulent both sides and what
happens it I say in America yeah I said
America that includes everybody and the
pro and and so what then happens is our
economic policies screw them and then we
go why you should pull yourself up by
your own bootstraps when the reality is
you think some politicians don't want to
get blacks out of their financials some
of these bad communities you don't think
they want them to let me become
independent making money you think some
people would like to keep them where
they're at let me be clear
in America
yes
in America yes because it's reflected in
our policies
talked to have Reverend William borrow
from the Publishers campaign and this is
not just it's reflected and it's not
just race Roland is that just race
Roland look because it's more broke
white folks in America than black
when you run a when you run a a business
and you have 40 000 agents Nationwide
and they're Hispanic uh 54 Hispanic uh
African-American this is our business I
have offices in Memphis I have offices
in Mississippi okay I have offices in
Chicago I have offices in uh uh you know
South Side I can go offices in I was
just in Calverton where's Calverton is
in um where's Calverton calverton's in
Baltimore or DC have offices in I go to
all the have offices in Tallahassee have
offices everywhere okay and I go visit
these places okay because it's what I
need to do to go check on these uh these
folks you have to realize
60 of our company
they're Democrats okay
I ain't got nothing to do what I'm
talking about but it but it does to me
because of course it does well yeah
you're saying in a sarcastic way I'll
tell you in my way because I want to
find out what we can do to improve and
if the data improves Republican policies
are doing better which they haven't had
a chance to do because I haven't had the
vote for that's a lot
92 has been voting Democrats
right here you act as a Republicans
haven't won
I don't think you understand if you're a
Republican and you win is the
African-American Studio Trump made a lot
of progress in your community
for where for where
income you want me to pull up the stats
for you pull it up with a net loss of
Jobs net loss of jobs you're counting
Culver don't do that when you're
counting stops
wait a minute so you don't bring up
coffee oh my God
what you just did validates why that
article about the appraisals being this
that's exactly what you just did no it's
not it doesn't tell the whole story
here's the deal right here here's the
deal I love this year this is what I
love about I love about with people
again go oh let's take out what happened
I know he was President not just him uh
same thing Obama if we take out 2009
okay oh my God this is what it looks
like I can't ignore 09 and o10 and 10.
we can't go well my goodness I know we
had a war when FDR was president look
when you the president you get the good
and you get the bad
the assessment is overall so so so the
pre-pre global pandemic he wasn't
helping African Americans he didn't he
was
unemployment everything wasn't going up
during Trump in the first three years so
once the pandemic hit that was bad news
are we now saying that the President is
responsible and gets credit for
unemployment
and of being low are we saying that I'm
saying every policy that he was doing to
help African Americans no what you said
you said everybody was once upon the
policy I said name the policy you said
unemployment rate that's not a policy
because the reality right now is
unemployment rate right now at the
lowest in 54 years including Trump the
black unemployment rate lowers in 54
years including Trump I'm asking you
said Trump helping policies I'm asking
what policy I didn't say policies I said
help helping African-Americans all know
you said policies can you name them can
you name them
I said 59 years got it you've had this
vote and how come you haven't met so in
the same 59 years you're gonna say
Republicans
the next question if a republican wins
are black folks still constituents of
course okay sure so when Republicans
have won yeah
show me again Republicans yeah whether
we're talking about State City County
State Governor or legislature and
Congress show me how lots of black
people have improved I've asked you
there are 10 or more Southern States
when you turn on every single news and
every single personality that says
Republican doesn't want the good for you
it's the Democrats that are here to help
you here's the deal yeah there's there
you've had 59 years and Republicans in
the same 59 years have been elected and
what did they do two percent of the vote
you've had for 59 years in the same 59
years they've won yeah and but you can't
but you simply are ignoring that but how
much has improved 27 hours and I'm
asking you in those same cities in those
same States who are still constituents
yeah here's what here's the thing that
again and this is what was you for some
reason I don't know like it was a block
in your brain
if you're a Republican and after this
African-Americans you vote for somebody
and your person don't win you are still
a constituent
and the reality is you are so you're
still a constituent it's so funny
because Ted Cruz gave an interview
yesterday yeah when he was jammed up
about by Margaret Brennan about Ted how
are you supporting a two-term living the
United States send them to run for your
third term he goes well because the 30
million Texans want me there not a lot
of Texas who didn't want you there but
we're still constituents so the question
still comes is Senator Ted Cruz what do
you do for African-Americans I can't act
as if you you're acting as if
Republicans have no responsibility
have don't have to do any policies
even when they win yeah oh it's all
Democrats and what I'm telling you is
what we're dealing with in this country
dealing with is you have one part that
historically over the last 50 plus years
has just completely like I ain't even
talking to you yeah I ain't talking to
you that's what you've had
well I'm over here you have Democrats
who have had some policies have had talk
let me real clear because I've jammed
them up on many things
absolutely should be doing more we talk
about rate of return I jammed up
President Obama directly saying I'm not
just I'm not just excited because you're
the first black president you still the
44th president and what I'm telling you
is because you won't answer that
question even in the places where
Republicans
have complete control
what are their policies what do you want
from them though you want them you want
CRT is that what you want here's what
would you like
what would you like I love how you just
don't want to throw that up here's what
I want yeah I want them to treat black
folks and Latinos or folks or anybody
who did not vote for them as
constituents they are what I don't know
they're not you think Democrats are
treating Republicans as constituents
wait wait wait no no excuse me Democrats
are treated nice deflection what time do
you live in no you're in the La La Land
yeah when Governor Tate Reeves when
Governor Tate Reeves of Mississippi
said and proudly said when I was a
treasurer of Mississippi
I purposely didn't send funds to Jackson
Mississippi
but now he wants to complain about
the Water Crisis
well dude what you were the treasurer
you neglect it
resources
what city supplies more of the state's
Revenue in Mississippi Jackson what
supplies more than sales tax revenue
Jackson but you wanted to deny the
resources to the very same city as
Republican and what I'm telling you is
now again I don't know why you just
somehow like rose-colored the issue I'm
saying is this here
if Republicans
want to be like Missouri show me find
show me but I'm telling you
I don't know how many black Republicans
you sat with but I've sat with a hell of
a whole lot and they're they're great
frustration is their own party won't
even listen to them have you talked to
Michael Steele Roland we talked Michael
Steele I have not I could not have a
problem having a mom okay he was a
brother who actually ran the Republican
National community
and he will openly tell you of the
absolute frustration he had with
Republican leaders on the very same
thing that we're talking about so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]